we've all heard of the Puritans this
champion tells you a lot more specifics
about who these people were and why they
were so important in early American
religious life the Puritans as the
Puritans long ago disappeared so they're
there unlike most of the other groups
that we're studying why are we actually
paying attention to them well you know
in a certain respect it's because they
ended up becoming churches the ones that
are still left are very anti puritanical
we'll talk about that in a moment but
they love to stamp on America and the
way which Americans think about being
the way you know being the kind of
people that they are the American
character that has not gone away that
too greatly outlived their physical
influence or their economic influence on
so if Puritan is actually at the
beginning of term of abuse like it both
talks about sort of like calling
somebody what do we help people who are
getting way too strict about things yeah
perfect example if Puritan is like that
originally the why are you know what are
they trying to purify they want to
purify the church actually the church
thing because they're English people of
everything I'll put this in quotes
because it's a very typical word they
have used around the time everything
Roman what do you think that meant
everything Catholic everything pre
Protestant so think about it you know
what I said it in one of the other
chapters if you were to go to a Lutheran
mass and a Roman Catholic Mass before
some of the recent
changes that were made which actually
made it a little bit more like hydrogen
lookin masses and certain respects it's
hard to tell the difference between them
because so much was held on to the
Puritans want to do away with all that
why do they want to do away with all
that because they think that those
things interfere with a person's
relationship with God they are getting
their theology originally from Calvinism
and like your book points out where did
they get all these ideas well some of
them had to go into exile and Calvinists
countries the English did because there
were you know politics going on and they
come back and they're like yeah you know
those those Geneva people they really
know what Christianity is about Church
of England it's just full of all sorts
of abuses what's the point in having a
Protestant Reformation if you're not
going all the way that's that's why
they're part of the radical Reformation
so they you know these ideas sort of
seek seep in and the university towns
like Oxford and Cambridge and then they
begin to exert an important role you
remember that by Elizabeth's time we
talked about this with the Anglicans the
Puritans are starting to become a real
thorn in her side she wants them to
knock it off and then we have King James
remember the King James Bible who was
that written to sort of rain in who
talked about interpretation and the fact
that every time you translate or
interpreting in a certain way it was
mainly oriented against the Puritans and
the Presbyterians for the the Church of
England so let you know like a put that
points out here's some of the complaints
they had about the Church of England
clergy were insufficiently rigorous in
their piety and morals meaning that they
weren't actually practicing what they
were preaching lacks and their doctrine
that means that they were believing
things that probably
both people eat liturgy as it was
celebrated was encumbered with too much
ceremony the lady lack discipline and
seriousness prophetic preferring to
spend the Sabbath in profane recreations
where would be profane with creations
getting drunk you know playing games
doing stuff like that you know the day
off when really that should be dedicated
solely to the Lord so it's a religion so
your book talks about James the first we
talked about him a little bit already
and then it brings up this guy here's
where the story takes a really important
part which are now let's get these
Charles at first you can usually tell
when somebody is a king who's not
particularly puffed particularly popular
because there won't be any sentence okay
anyone else named neck so Charles um
puts this guy in charge remember Charles
is the king so who does he get to a
point near remember the Anglican Church
yeah it's not very good so he promotes
this guy William long and you remember
what I was talking about Calvinism we
also talked about Arminianism your
minions one of the things that goes
along with the Calvinist doctrine is a
view that you really don't have free
will God saves really saves you cannot
really do anything about it arminius
wanted to assert no human beings actions
you have a free will and he actually
started out as a Calvinist I turned
against it will then one in England
takes the side of our meetings so that
you know makes the Puritans quite
unhappy at the same time the Puritans
were growing in empower and popular like
it points out Parliament was coming
under the control of the newer
mercantile
one economic interests do you this is a
major transformation and English
economic and political life and these
people were very attracted by Puritanism
by you know higher ideals by a more
rigorous strict way of life Charles was
not a particularly good king and then he
did another thing that really took
people off you married a Catholic and
then he sort of threw the dice he
dissolved parliament and if you don't
know much about the history of England
King and Parliament were often in
opposition to each other Parliament was
needed because it was supposed to be in
a representative and Parliament could
also raise money so if the King could
find money on his own he would and he
didn't want to deal with the arguments
and stuff like that he dismissed
Parliament that's what this guy did
eventually he has to reconvene them
because he gets into a war with Scotland
and when they get together you know how
is it would like you blow somebody off
and then later on you go back to them
and say yeah ken need some help from how
does that pan out they usually happy to
see you they have more complaints
Parliament did and the king you know he
didn't want to hear that either civil
war breaks out now the King actually
loses and then this guy Oliver Cromwell
takes over yeah he's a Puritan and he is
damaged as a Puritan state in England
and they close down a lot of stuff that
was going out now Cromwell named himself
of Lord protectors
and it was essentially you know a new
kind of monarchy without King and in
many respects it was one of the first
totalitarian states of the modern era
and as you can expect things didn't go
that well and eventually Cromwell gets
kids he doesn't get food that his son is
unable to keep things together and the
English decide they want to King back
because even a king would be better than
these Puritans being in charge and now
the Puritans are once again in the
minority and a lot of the Puritans start
thinking about we need to get out of
here we need to go somewhere else so now
a lot of times people will get these two
groups mixed up um coke rooms are kind
of Puritan like when you know you do
your you're a kid remember doing like
the thanksgiving stuff put your hand
make the turkey with the hand and maybe
some of you dress up as pilgrims and
some of you dress up his native
americans and I don't know maybe made
cornbread in class and ate it together
or something like that that's a long
time ago when we remember those were the
pilgrims the pilgrims are the ones who
come over first they're the ones on the
Mayflower they were actually Puritans
they were Puritans who are so hardcore
that they believed you absolutely had to
separate from the tritium could not do
before the rest of the Puritans the rest
of the pyramids have always misspelling
network thought that know you the Church
of England is pretty rough but you could
at least still do something with that
and so they were not as hard work these
guys are the ones who land first and
they don't actually do very much after
they land the Puritans are the ones that
land in Massachusetts
and spread out and they're the ones who
establish the presents a new so um much
time that we got go through this fairly
quickly so they talked about this whole
these holy Commonwealth's and a holy
Commonwealth is not only a religious
organization it's a political
organization it's a way of arranging not
only church governance but political
governance and so church and state are
in many respects going hand-in-hand not
exactly the same people because if you
were saying minister you you couldn't
serve as a member of the state these
organizations but for the most part
these are supposed to be very focused
Geneva like societies they talk about a
sort of release valve for this to
another state that's going to attain an
important role so if Puritans are in
Massachusetts and Connecticut mean at
that time it was party Massachusetts
whether or not it's not sure how that
worked but for a long time in this part
of Massachusetts and then New Hampshire
what state will stay to my leaving at ya
know what happened in Rhode I down there
exactly so if you read through some of
the literature of the peer exchange
you'll your references to people like
this Roger Williams and rhode island was
a place where there wasn't any state
church there wasn't any required form of
worship as a matter of fact a lot of
people weren't religious at all there's
a famous incident that any of you ever
read about this in your American lit
classes the with the may pole just ring
a bell for anybody that
there used to be an old ritual having
maypole we don't really do this much in
but it was part of the celebration of
spring just you know google it you'll
see what maypoles look like they have
all sorts of you know like a nice
colorful emblems on them usually ribbons
and then people dance around you know
dance around the Maypole and then
sometimes they'd get drunk and you know
start doing all sorts of other things
like hooking up with each other so you
know some people so it is kind of a
pagan ritual and it may heaven some some
oranges and pay homage right and they
directed one of these that one item and
the Puritans found out about this what
do you think they did well those those
reprobates they're just going to do
their sort of thing leave them alone let
the Panther fun they're all going to
hell anyway well I came and cut it down
because they're not going to have that
sort of idol worship on the shores of
the new Israel the new place where for
you know it hasn't happened for a very
long time where God can be with the holy
people and everything can be purified of
any sort of the dollar tree or sin or
stains of that sort this is one incident
that it's kind of telling and you can
actually what's nice about this one is
you can actually read about it from both
perspectives in American literature what
are some of the distinctives about these
well a lot of its going to be coming
from reformed tradition which we've
already talked about but there's some
distinctive things with the Puritans
that made them different from from
Calvin's Genevan followers or the
Presbyterians or other reform groups one
of these is the notion of Haifa Bay Rays
some of this history stuff now one of
these is the notion of covenant and
we've talked about this before right
that's an agreement some sort that
sealed with some
solemnity we had Israel in the Bible has
a covenant with Yahweh God Lord Lord by
the way euphemism because they didn't
want to say Yahweh so they say Greek
kurios the Lord this notion of covenant
not only has to do it with the whole
communities relationship with God it has
to do with individuals relation with God
but it can also be extended to the
political community and it can also be
extended to marriage and marriage comes
to be seen for the Puritans not as a
sacrament but it's a covenant between
between the husband and wife and
Covenants you know we're sure like
contracts they come with year and do
this I'm going to do this this is the
terms of the agreement so to speak what
else so we've got covenant oh yeah let's
call this concern about one's spiritual
state and you know there's only two
spiritual States basically for the
Puritans remember the our Calvinists
calvinist believe in predestination this
is no purgatory for them so where where
are your two options ultimately that's
it there's no third place everybody is
either to save and if you save your one
of the Saints one of the Holy or your DM
and there's this preoccupation with
trying to figure out how can you tell
this is something we talked about a
little bit last class didn't way how do
you know if you're actually safe he had
so like they said they started to
develop a a description what they call
morphology the distinct phases that
characterized religious development of
many believers I started trying to plot
this out somebody who saved would go
through
this this state in this state and this
would happen to them and along with that
they started to begin tightening the
requirements for full church membership
in order to really be a full member of
the church you would need to be able to
demonstrate that you were saved now
that's kind of tough to do how do you
think that that you would go about maybe
you could actually like say I'm God can
you let them know send them up something
an email know that I'm one of the elect
I mean that's not gonna if that did work
that would be extraordinary but that
sort of thing almost never happens this
per say no so you've got to go buy some
sort of upward sign how can you tell if
somebody's safe you look at how weird
behavior if they're if they're drinking
all the time and cheating on their
husband or wife probably they're not
safe as a matter of fact that's like a
guarantee they're not saved look out
people who are going about their daily
stuff and following the rules I can be
sure for that another way you might look
at whether they prosper does God
rewarding bless them or does God you
know punish them for some sort of secret
sin you know so like think about if you
go into business you start a business
for yourself let's say you become a
Cooper use that example you got some raw
materials all the barrel series and
probably you're here hoping to work
those out yourself and then you gotta
get the Rings and you got actually for
mum and your business just doesn't take
off well you might you might actually be
damned that might be a sign that your
name on the ugly manage of business
prospers then you become somebody
influential the community that's
probably a sign that God is blessing you
are probably although not guaranteed
want to be alive why do you could like
to look anyway though this is what they
started to do they started to
require that a person actually give and
it comes to the other church members to
approve the church members of their own
interior internal spiritual development
you could call it what's actually using
the term because this is what they often
call this religious autumn biography
conversion narrative I used to be a
sinner but then I started to feel you
know bad about the things that I was
doing well actually i'll let me play it
in sort of analogy i used to be a
terrible teacher i used to sign way too
much reading to the students and when
they ask questions i would berate them
and call them stupid and then a little
still voice inside of me when I saw the
tears of my my students eyes during
office hours said to me you are a bad
man and I felt convicted convicted of my
sin against my my my neighbor students
and then I began to feel qualms and as i
did this i started to experiment and I
tried to be nice to my students and not
make them feel like they were lazy and
stupid where they asked questions and
then I could see you know that God was
blessing both of us indeed because I
could see the smile on their face as the
light bulb went on above their head and
they got it this is a very secular form
of this right and then I began to
realize that other people were good
teachers and I went to them and I said
what's good teaching and I learned from
that and watched them and saw how they
dealt with students in a much more kind
and caring way and well-prepared way not
sure we have two lectures without
knowing what you're going to talk about
that would be like a conversion
right so this could be done in religion
as well how did you move away from you
know the state of original sin and the
damage that it's done to a solid
relationship with John that's what was
required to be a full member of the
church so that's a little bit different
than the other other Calvinists where
you would be more external things that
they be looking if you wanted to take
communion if you wanted to be a voting
member in the church or in the society
you have to do that it talks about
Harvard education but I'm actually going
to skip over that maybe we'll talk about
that another time economics this is
something where you spend a little time
talking about a book that that's very
important whether you buy into its
interpretation or not have only favorite
red mock slavers the Protestant ethic in
the spirit of capitalism in any classes
sociology majors or psychology majors
now for the reading you may not buy
internet but he's making an argument
there that economic development and
Puritanism kind of went hand-in-hand
Calvinism in general why well if you're
living a Puritan way of life probably
not spending a lot of money right where
do people tend to waste a lot of money
let's think about our society if you
want to rein in your spending habits
what should you quit doing that's a big
one and if you're going to drink you
should drink at home and buy in bulk and
not go to the bar right right or really
go to extreme home room that takes an
awful long time so drinking that's a big
one the Puritans aren't drinking what
else what else do we spend money on very
good yeah if you're not trying to be
fashionable you can wear the same thing
over and over again just you know it
gets a hold of it put a patch on it's
all going to be black anywhere brown so
notice what else what are other things
where you could cut costs eating out
very good mm-hmm I mean it's not like
there were a lot of restaurants there
anyway but you wouldn't spend money on
fancy fancy food so you see where this
is going right if you're living a cenic
way of life it's a pretty cheap way to
live that means that if you're actually
productive you're generating a lot of
surplus cash or goods the way capitalism
works is the surplus is then reinvested
into means of production to generate yet
more stuff so the Puritan way of life is
actually instrumental in the development
of capitalism now the other side of this
is remember these guys are worried about
whether they're safe and material
prosperity is a sign of God's blessing
then you're going to work really hard so
that you can be sure that you're blessed
because you can never be entirely sure
maybe you still have some secrets team
that's going to send you down down down
home so you've gotta work work work work
work work work as a matter of fact you
know one thing that the Puritans did not
celebrate with any sort of festivities
Christmas matter of fact Christmas was
seen as kind of an alien custom in large
parts of America early on we that seemed
very strange to us because we were used
to everybody you know whether we're
religious or not that we get off on that
day and you know do Secret Santas or you
know things like that right for that
that was that was you don't do that they
also talked about vary enormously
mention this very quickly this plane
style and aesthetics and that's that's
worth thinking about the last thing
since I'm not going to get through
everything here that I want to hit up we
talked about this before with some with
just earlier than today
what happens when you go from one
generation to various started up being
on fire having a very solid you know
community everybody is on the same page
how does that usually work after a
couple generations what happens what
kind of changes somebody said change
thank you what kind of changes I think
about the traditions that you have in
your own family that your grandparents
actually insisted on quite so big on
that maybe now then you can dispense
with that if you have a grandparents of
a real and system that stuff the same
thing happens in the Puritan community
they start you know having people who
are like yeah this is really for me and
it leads to a lot of problems because in
order to be a full member of the
community not a second-class citizen you
gotta buy your knowledge sort of stuff
so eventually this is going to lead to
the kind of collapse of Puritanism as
such where does it remain this is what
when where do we still see Puritanism as
a major part of the manitowoc the book
talks about the work ethic and this
notion that you better you better get
out there and work you don't deserve a
vacation get out there and work and make
something of yourself and that's what
it's like to be godly it is it tidy we
don't say that in terms of godliness now
we put in moral terms what are you some
sort of prom get out there and work
you're not here to have a good time
that's that's where we'll leave up I
don't and I don't mean for you not to at
the time having a touch them up here